hello Vsauce Michael here and today I
have 16 more creative games just for you
so why wait let's hit the ground running
or rather DJ record trippin takes the
feeling and live soundtrack mixing up
scratching a record with your scroll
wheel and transposes it onto other
objects like a wooden maze pressure if
more a windmill you can scratch the plan
to baleen seed famous objects from
classic movies looks really slick and is
a great way to test your movie knowledge
it's like hangman but you only get three
mistakes this one's less of a game and
more of a Laboratory of color in math it
replicates a viewing window to create a
kaleidoscopic image look I made a V for
Vsauce kind of in touch the bubbles you
/ cute little balls with your mouth
while carefully navigating away from red
stop but if you want something more
human try P me in this game you're a
superhero who must dodge the poop
monsters attacks while collecting
lemonade from friendly girls so you can
pee on it
prefer secretions from the other end try
spewer this little guy wants to get to
the exit but sometimes he needs a puke
thrust adding to the game's complexity
you can swim in your own puke to avoid
dangers and eat it back up again for
future use
chaos escape might give you a heart
attack you have to move your mouse
around the screen as violent industrial
shapes fly around in perfect sync with
pounding techno avoid the red stuff and
be sure to turn on your scroll blind
music catch - is exactly the same except
the opposite its shapes are synced with
soothing piano music that breathes
around you catch the yellow notes for
points and to grow larger and purple
ones to quickly grab safe shapes avoid
the red notes and relax if your job is
so terrible you can't relax and you'd
rather die here's a game where you play
an office worker and the entire point is
to kill yourself but if suicide isn't
really your thing and you'd rather find
a way to have fun while working just
make it look like you're working exit is
a simple game that appears to be an
Excel spreadsheet when really it's just
you bouncing around off the walls
let's get puzzle interlock is great
you're given 3d puzzles that you can
inspect and then move around and pull up
but for a more organic field play the
role of a tree and choose how to grow so
that you wind up collecting rings it's
much tougher than you'd imagine sugar
sugar lets you draw on lines with your
mouse to make paths for sugar to fall
into cups it's relaxing and sweet thank
you if you prefer mechanics to drawing
play grain string where you have to drag
in the right machinery to transport
grain into a bucket packs on is a
creative mashup where you play pac-man
complete with power-ups food and ghosts
zip carefully to close them in until
it's so claustrophobic that you get to
move to the next level and as a fitting
way to end this video you have to burn
the Rope is probably the flash game with
the best ending ever but luckily our
journey doesn't have to end there
because guess what there's a new episode
of loot on vsauce2 click here to watch
it and figure out what these are
subscribe to Vsauce 2 for the win and as
always thanks for watching